Hello, everybody!
Hello, hello!
Sorry I had to push the stream up by 30 minutes because I needed to sleep!
Why must I needed to sleep?
Well, I got fucking baited!
What do you mean by baited, Doki?
Alright, so, story time!
Story time!
So, yesterday, I was really nervous.
I was really, really nervous because I saw that...
Numbers were getting... The top 500 leaderboards for Marble Rivals was, like, climbing.
And I got really, really scared.
So, I was like... I was like to the Super Gomez...
I was like, man, I'm scared.
It feels like the numbers are going so fast.
Why?
Are you sure I'm safe?
And then... Sorry, my brain is still powering up because I literally just slept for, like, two hours.
So, I had two hours of sleep.
But after this stream, I'm gonna sleep some more.
And then we're going back tomorrow.
Anyway, so I was just like, I'm getting really scared.
Because, you know, it seems like it's climbing really fast.
Are you sure my number is safe?
And then... They thought about it for a while now.
And they're like, it's time to get on.
It's time.
Let's go gambling!
We just need to win two games.
And I'm like, are you sure?
Are you sure we take that risk?
And they're like, yeah!
Fuck it!
We lost three games in a row.
And then... Alright...
Anyway... Anyway, so... Guys...
Maybe let's not go gambling.
So... Anyway... Anyway... Yeah, you fucking stalkers.
I know you guys were looking at... You guys were looking at my progress.
Anyway, so...
After that, it was... At one point, I was stuck at 200 points for 8 plus hours.
Like, I'm not even gonna hide the fact how long it took me to...
It took me the entire night and a little bit of the day...
To get back to what I was before.
And also be plus 20 more points than what I was.
So now I'm 285.
I'm 285.
And I hope... I hope it's safe.
I... I... I... Anyway...
Anyway, can anyone tell me what the cutoff... Anyone who has the leaderboard up, I would love to know what the cutoff is right now.
Because I think I have like 3 to 4 more hours now.
So like, we're assuming that 280... Oh, it's still 251!
Anyway, during the middle of... Oh, it's at 258 right now.
Okay, I think it's safe.
I think... I think it's... I think it's safe.
I... No, no, no.
I'm second-doubting myself again.
It climbed to 7 points within the 2 hours I was napping.
Oh my god, it should be safe.
Toki, don't think about it.
Toki, Toki, don't think about it.
It should be safe.
Don't think about...
Okay, anyway.
Anyway.
Anyway, so...
That's why I had to push the stream 30 minutes more.
Because I was like, I can't... I need to sleep.
And then...
I could've just played in the morning, but they were like, what if you don't make it?
And I was like, oh my god, what if I don't make it?
I invested so... What if I don't make it?
And then I showed up.
And then they were like, it's E5.
Let's go gambling.
And I'm like, but god... I'm so easily... I'm so easily convinced to do anything.
I'm...
I'm just so...
It's like they're like, oh, but what if... And you're like, you're right.
You're right.
Let me get on right now.
Let me... Let me get on right now.
I fooled it.
I got baited.
I fooled it so easily.
And then I had to... Oh my god.
And then now I'm here.
It's okay.
They're like... And then like...
My manager was like, it's okay if you cancel the bilateral...
And I'm like, I will not cancel the bilateral stream.
Marvel Rivals does not dictate my life.
I am in control.
I was like, I refuse to cancel bilateral because of Rivals.
I am in control of my life.
So that's why I'm here too.
That's why I'm still here.
Because I still really, really wanted to stream for you guys.
But did not want to stream Marvel Rivals.
I was gonna be streaming Marvel Rivals at like 1 in the morning.
But I did not want to replace today's stream with Rivals.
I am in control of my own destiny.
Anyway, I'm okay, guys.
By the way, I'm...
I'm in control.
Anyway.
Another update.
I got invited to do the Marvel Rivals Twitch Rivals.
Well, not invited.
I literally pestered the Twitch staff like three...
Like several times to be like, hey, I heard about the Marvel Rivals Twitch Rivals.
Can I be in it?
They're like, hey, oh yeah.
Sorry, we're on vacation.
We gotta check later.
I was like, alright.
And then like one or two days later, I was like, so do you still have a spot?
And they're like, oh, well, let me look into it.
And I'm like, oh, cool.
Please let me know if you do.
And then like finally, they're like, oh, yeah.
Are you sure you really want...
We might be able to do something.
And they're like, are you sure you really want the spot?
I was like, yeah, I love the spot.
I was like, let me in!
I'm just like, yeah.
I basically like pushed them.
I basically was like at the door.
Let me in!
So I'm now like, I will be participating in the Marvel Rivals, Twitch Rivals.
And like, oh my God, like I'm a team captain for it.
So I'm bringing my own team there.
And like the competition is very...
I can't leak the captains.
There's...
It's fucking weird.
All I'm saying is that because I asked them, can they show me the teams that they're getting?
And so like I know competitively like who I'm going to get.
And then like I looked at the list and like literally like I believe like half the captains are incredible try hard FPS streamers.
And then half of them, they're going to get absolutely destroyed.
I saw the team list and I was like, oh man.
I know for sure that this team captain is going to bring a full try hard roster.
And then there's a team that's just Minecraft players.
And then I was like, oh man.
I was like,
oh, that does not look ideal for that team over there.
I was looking at the captains and like who they're bringing.
I'm like, oh, what the fuck?
This team brought like an entire professional team.
And then this other team is just Minecraft.
What could possibly go wrong?
So anyway, the limitations is that I can bring four players.
I mean, three players, including me.
But basically I can bring like four players, including me.
That's above diamond rank.
So obviously I'm going to choose one above all because I don't want to get absolutely destroyed on stream.
So but like some teams, it's just like they would only have one player.
That's one above all.
And then the rest is really like the rest is like diamond, diamond players.
I'm like, why?
You have an option to bring four players.
That's diamond or above.
Why the fuck would you bring it?
Like, why would you choose?
Obviously, I'm bringing four players.
That's one above all.
I'm not.
And then the other two.
I mean, I'm bringing three players.
That's going to be one above all.
And then two players are going to be like below diamond.
And I'm like, that is...
For the five...
Guys, it's not going to be fives when I fucking get full held in spawn.
I refuse to be full held.
That's not fives, guys.
That's absolutely not fives.
It doesn't matter if you're like, oh man, but these are my fives.
They're not going to be possible.
I saw the team's list, guys.
I saw it.
It was literally like...
Okay.
Like, one of the captains is fucking Shroud.
Do you really think Shroud's going to be like, alright guys, let me bring the easy...
You really...
I know Shroud's bringing pro players into the tournament.
And then the other team was minecrafters.
Oh my god.
I'm like, you really...
I know like...
And I already know some of the...
Because like, it wasn't in the team's list.
But I already know some of the players that Shroud's assembling.
And some of them were from the tournament.
And I was like, bro.
I'm going to do that.
That's like...
I was like, I'm not here to get absolutely destroyed.
I am not here.
Oh, it's alright.
They don't watch me on YouTube anyway.
Like...
Oh, so by the way.
I got double...
Okay.
I got like, double, triple confirmed.
That like...
That's fucked.
But I'm also...
Yes, if they're going to do it, I'm going to do it too.
Also, another update.
I found out that like...
You know how I was like, oh yeah.
Like, I was getting stream sniped almost like every day when I was streaming on Twitch.
I...
Double, triple confirmed that like...
During the fucked up hours, I was trying to make sure I was secure in top 500.
They were like, yeah.
They saw that it was like a way...
They saw that you were sort of like, you know.
It would have been so easy to get points off of you.
Because, you know, you were stacking with us.
And obviously...
And I'm like...
And you were obviously, you know, not a pro player.
So like, they also made that for stack.
Because you were just so...
You know.
And I was like, that's fucked up.
I was like...
I'm just a little guy.
That's actually so fucked up.
They're like, yeah.
Like, you know.
It was just...
Out of the...
Like, you know.
Since...
Since you're...
You're obviously going to go against the stack.
You were obviously like, you know, the weakest link.
And it would be very easy to get points off of it.
I'm like, that's so fucked up.
Like, I...
I'm just a little guy.
I'm literally...
Bro, they literally like, fucking...
Like, I'm a baby.
And they literally like, saw the baby in the playground.
And they just like, grabbed the baby.
And then just chucked it into the ocean.
Because they're like, oh, look at her.
That's...
That's basically how I felt after finding that out.
Anyway.
But outro.
We're...
Sorry.
Now, that's the life update for everybody.
That's why I had to push the stream 30 minutes.
And like, a lot of stuff happened in between yesterday and today.
Because I'm fucking weak.
To like, I guess...
I'm very weak and easily persuadable to do certain things.
And sadly, I was very weak.
And like, they're like, I don't know.
Maybe it's not safe.
You should get on.
And I was like, you're right.
I should get on.
Okay.
Alright.
So, I also need you guys to know.
I didn't record the session.
Because like, after we lost three games in a row at the beginning.
I was like, this is not gonna be a good time.
I had a feeling.
So I just like, stopped recording anything.
But I definitely crashed out during that grind.
Because I went to bed at 2 PM.
So, or 3 PM.
So like, it was not a great day.
It was not a great night.
And at one point, I kept getting targeted.
By this fucking Black Panther.
And then like, in my stack.
They were like, whoa Doki.
Because I was like, I hope your family dies.
In game.
Because I was so...
And then like, it was said with so much like, vitriol.
I was like, I was so tired.
I was so tired of this Black Panther.
Diving me every time.
And then I was like, and then when he dived me one last time.
I was like, I hope your family dies.
In game.
And then my entire group was like, whoa.
Because I didn't hit that level of like, I'm so done before.
Until that moment.
I was just incredibly done.
Alright, Bellatro.
Bellatro.
So, I have no idea what this game is about.
But I have heard a lot of good things about it.
Like, everybody was telling me how like, it's incredibly addicting.
Which is great.
Like, someone was like, I saw some people in my chat was like.
That's great that you're trying to replace your alcoholic addiction with smoking.
That's bad.
They're like, wow.
Good for you.
For ruining, you're trying to ruin your life via other means now.
So, I'm a little worried now because of it.
Because everyone was telling me that this game is incredibly addicting.
And that it's also, it's like, people can play like, super long hours.
And like, a lot of people try to do like, treatments for it.
Like, trying to get like, finish some runs.
Oh my gosh.
Also like, I didn't read the full email.
But somebody like, I don't know.
Somebody sent, like my manager told me that somebody sent an email.
Trying to, like giving me a tutorial of how to beat the first level.
I guess like, because they were worried about me.
I didn't read it.
So like, I'm sorry.
Sorry.
I didn't read it.
So like, I guess you're gonna still have to suffer.
I'm sorry.
I had other things to worry about.
Also, Kilandria, thank you for the 50 gifted chips.
Thank you, thank you.
I really appreciate it.
And thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hello, Mitoki.
Don't worry, Mito.
I'm also stupid.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Sombra, thank you for the super chat.
This game is weirdly addicting.
Fortunately, you're already a rival's addict.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, that's why I'm a little worried.
Because apparently, it's incredibly addicting.
And I'm already like, suffering via other addictions at the moment.
So like, I don't know if it's good to combine two addictions.
Bite Size, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey, Doki.
Today is my birthday.
Last year started very rough for me, but ended absolutely incredible.
Better than I could have hoped.
I want to say thank you for being a big reason why it turned out so great.
I'm very happy to share this day with you and the Drakkos.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Bite Size, thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Bite Size.
Yeah!
Thank you again for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, so like I said, I have no idea what's going...
I have no idea how to play this game.
So we're going to learn as...
I'm going to go in blind, as always.
I'm going to go in fucking blind.
What's the worst that could happen?
My entire chat yelling at me as I play the wrong card?
What else is new?
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
Loutro!
I don't know...
It's been a while, Sound Guy.
I hope you're still alive.
Like, I...
I hope you're still alive, but it's time.
We're coming back to the sound now.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait a minute.
This isn't Marvel Rivals.
Can't believe the title isn't Clickbait.
Shake my head.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, it's time.
It's Belotro time.
Uh...
Hello there.
My name is Jimbo.
Also, Nick, welcome to the tomato farm.
Tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
I'm here to help you learn how to play.
Hello.
Your goal is to earn chips to defeat the enemy blind.
This here is a small blind.
You only need to score 300 chips to beat it.
Select the small blind to start the round.
Oh my gosh, also 300 dollars?
That should be fine.
What am I gonna do?
End up selling my house after this?
Uh, Kalandria, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
This game ruined me.
Hope it does the same to you.
No one except Belotro, alright?
Cheer.
Uh, you earn chips by playing poker heads.
Each poker head...
Wait, am I supposed to know how to play poker?
I... wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
Am I... am I supposed to learn how to...
Am I supposed to know?
Oh, thank God.
Okay, cause I don't know how to play poker.
I absolutely have no idea what the rules are to poker.
Each poker head earns a base amount of chips multiplied by some mult.
See your poker hands in the run info area.
Along with other info about your current run.
Okay.
Straight flush five cards in a row.
Oh, Q, J.
Wait, what about king?
Oh, eight, nine, ten.
J, queen, king.
Four cards with the same...
With the same rank.
They may be played with one other unscored card.
Oh, it teaches me!
High card.
Only the highest card.
Two cards that...
Oh my God, I'm learning.
And should they maybe play with three others?
Okay.
Two pair.
It's a... what's the...
Two pairs, different ranks may be played with one other unscored card.
Oh!
Three of a kind.
Oh, that's what this means.
Seven, eight, nine...
Wait.
With all cards.
Oh, if it's the same suit.
Oh!
A three of a kind and a pair.
Okay.
I'm learning.
Cards also earning you some chips.
Hover over to see.
Okay, ten chips.
Now select up to five cards to play the hand.
Uh...
I have a pair.
Oh my God, I don't remember.
Pair.
They maybe play with three under...
There you go.
Wait, but I could do...
Full house.
Uh...
No, I could do...
Yeah, I should do that.
I should do nine, nine, seven, five...
Where did you get the...
Okay, here.
This should be it.
Play hand.
There you go.
I got a pair.
And then I can play the random cards.
You can also discard up to five selected cards.
I'll just...
I'll discard this one.
I'll need a six, seven, eight...
J Queen King.
Oh my God!
I have a full...
I have a...
I have the thing!
You only have a limited number of...
Okay, I got this.
I'm learning.
Earn 300 chips before you run...
Watch this.
Six, seven, eight, J Queen King.
Hey, yo!
Where's my king?
Wait!
Wait a minute.
Where did my king go?
Where...
Six, seven, eight...
Wait, what happened to my king?
What...
What happened?
Oh, I play...
I need...
Oh, numbers.
Oh, wait.
Numbers.
I can't count.
And so, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I won most I had by spying jokers and planet cards.
Works every time, 80% of the time.
And so, thank you for the super chat though.
The numbers, man.
Five, six, seven, eight.
Okay, what can I...
Does that work?
Seven.
No, I need to beat five cards.
No!
Um...
Flush?
Eight, ten.
Wait, what's a flush again?
Flush.
I share the same suit.
Oh!
Oh, one, two, three, four.
But I only have four.
Oh, wait.
If I discard...
I'll discard the five.
I'll discard the five and the six.
And then, maybe I'll get a flush.
And then, seven.
And then, maybe...
I can get a flush.
Up to five.
Oh, you're right.
Who needs the king as well?
You're right.
Alright.
Okay, that's not really what I wanted, but...
Um...
That's okay.
That's not...
I'm...
That's not what I wanted, but that's...
How many discards do I get?
I get two more discards.
Okay, but I do have two pairs.
And like, that's cooler than a flush, right?
Okay.
I'm with two pairs.
And one other unscored card.
And I don't need a three.
There we go.
Two pairs suck?
But...
A flush is better, but what if I don't get the flush?
What if I don't get it?
What happened to my...
8, 1, 2, 3, 4.
I literally need one more.
Alright.
Nice.
There we go.
Yay!
Bam!
There's a flush right there.
Wait, I need 300.
Wait a minute.
I... Oh, I got it!
Oh my gosh.
Easiest game of my life.
God, I'm...
Oh, there we go.
I'm so fucking smart.
Didn't re-chat at all for that.
JR, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, can't get addictive.
Don't know how to smoke it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Guys, thank you, thank you.
Alright.
It's a...
That's slow?
What do you mean?
Oh my god, it's on the slowest speed.
That's slow?
It's...
It's going by incredibly fast for me.
Nicely done.
Now that you're flushed with cash, you can buy some new cards from the shop.
But I can buy new...
Try buying the handsome devil.
Okay.
Alright.
This is one of the one...
Oh, bring down the music?
Okay, let me bring down the music.
After this.
This is one of the 150 jokers you can add to your run.
Every joker does something different.
What's molt?
To your hand...
To every hand you play.
Be picky.
You can only carry five jokers at a time.
Now buy the other card.
Empress.
Enhance two...
What the fuck is a molt card?
Oh, it's...
Multiply.
Okay.
Oh, it means multiply.
Okay, I get it.
This tarot card is a consumable.
This one has your playing cards.
Hold on to it.
You can carry up to two consumable cards with you at a time.
They say enough you can buy a voucher.
Vouchers passively upgrade your run.
Vouchers are restocked after you defeat the boss blind.
And check out bo...
Oh no, not the booster packs.
Oh no, I thought I was done with you.
I...
I thought I was done with you.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Um, they're full of goodies.
Let's move on to the next round.
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, let me bring it...
Bring up...
The game volume.
And then...
It's like a...
Okay.
Oh, okay.
So every time I do a play, I just have to throw two cards.
Um...
Uh...
Welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
If you beat it...
Then...
Uh...
The ante goes up and all the blinds become harder.
Beat ante 8 to win.
Now choose your path.
No, I fucking...
I ain't no coward.
Alright, let me...
Let me...
Oh, I can up...
Alright, it's already really fast.
Like, I...
I just woke up, guys.
I can't...
I just...
Guys...
I just woke up.
I...
I can't do it faster, guys.
Like, please.
Have mercy.
I know.
I...
I know you guys like it fast.
But I...
My brain is still adjusting right now.
When you get more cards, remember you can rearrange them.
Joker triggers in order from left to right.
Make sure that you use your consumables.
Okay.
Slap two cards in hand and press use on a tarot card to enhance them.
Wait, but like...
What happens when I enhance them?
Oh, does it make the points...
Does it make the chips higher?
Does it make it higher?
Is that what it does?
I'll just put it on the Js.
Oh, okay.
Let's do it.
Alright.
What are you?
Oh my god.
You're J but cooler.
The cooler Js.
Okay.
Alright.
We got the cooler Js right here.
Um...
What do I do with you?
What?
Two, three, four, five?
Wait, what?
Oh my gosh.
I already forgot.
A three of a kind and a pair.
Oh, wait.
Three of a kind and a pair?
Wait.
Maybe I can do it.
Guys.
Guys, but like...
Two pairs is bad.
I could do...
Guys.
Just think.
I could get...
I could...
I could literally get...
Wait.
I could literally get three of a kind and a pair, guys.
I can...
I can get a full house.
That's right.
Just...
Let's go gambling.
What's the worst that could happen?
I said like yesterday.
Did I truly learn what happened to me yesterday?
Let's go gambling.
You know what?
I still have three more discards.
Wait.
JQueenKing.
What's the worst that could happen?
What's the worst that could happen, guys?
I mean...
Just think about...
3, 4, 5...
3, 4...
I got two more.
You're right.
Gamblers...
Gamblers quit at 99% before they hit it.
You're so right, guys.
You're so fucking right.
Guys, I...
You're right all in.
You're fucking right.
What's the
worst...
I mean...
It's alright.
Two pairs.
I've always wanted to play two pairs.
I forgot to play the fifth card.
I forgot.
We won anyway.
It's fine.
We already won.
Wait, I could've just won the game in the first fucking play?
I...
Okay.
Alright.
I didn't realize that.
I could've just won the game at that.
That's right.
There you go.
Never punish, guys.
I'll never learn.
Oh, but I can buy...
Permanently gain one hand?
Wait.
I want a permanent voucher.
Okay.
I'll get a voucher.
Nice.
I get one hand.
Yeah.
I'll take that.
Victor, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
God gave you all these scars for a reason.
Let's go gambling.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Now I'm broke, but that's okay.
Next round.
I feel like it's gonna come in handy.
I mean, it's like...
Oh, I get to fight the big boss.
Alright.
Let's grab two random cards per hand played.
Oh, okay.
So I have to multi.
Five, six...
Wait, I have hearts.
Okay, but like...
Oh, but it's random.
Right?
Oh.
Wait, it's random.
Oh, this is bad.
It's the same rank that we played.
Oh, I need like...
Oh.
Oh, it's random.
It's...
Played, not discard.
Oh, it's not discarded.
So I can still gamble.
Okay, I don't need any...
I don't need these.
Okay.
We might be able to get another heart.
And then we'll do like four or five...
Yeah, I can get another heart from this.
One, two...
Okay.
I can still get another heart, guys.
Guys, I can...
One, two, three, four...
Wait, wait, wait, wait!
One, two, three, four, five!
Wait, I got it!
I got flesh!
I'm sorry, I have to count right again.
I'm worried.
I'm...
I'm worried I can't count.
I'm worried.
Oh my God, I kept my G!
Let's fucking go!
Did I win?
Wait, this... Wait.
Oh no, I need a hundred more.
Okay.
Two, two...
Wait, I can just do two pairs and then I win.
Fucking, this game is for babies.
Wait.
If I just do two pairs, I literally just win.
Wait, is this game supposed to be hard?
I got the multiplayer.
440...
Yeah!
This game is for fucking babies.
You know what?
Maybe gambling ain't so bad.
Hello, Casino.
Would you...
Okay.
Brunei, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I swear to God, every V2 I watched that tried Ballaltro for the first time always succeeded on two pairs.
You either go big or go home, Brunei.
I ain't no pussy.
We gotta go for the top scores.
We're not here to play safe.
Alright.
Choose one of up to three playing cards to add to your deck.
Wait, do I buy...
That's my gambling stream.
Yeah.
Top scores, please.
Look, I guaranteed the win.
I was fine.
Let's see.
Oh, what's this?
The Joker gains for each card sold.
Resets when boss blind is defeated.
What about buying the Joker card?
Bus Joker.
The Joker gains plus one multiplier per consecutive hand played.
Wait, that's insane.
It's ass?
The bus sounds like it's gonna be crazy.
Alright, I'm ready.
Next round.
Alright.
I'm ready for the tiny one.
Are we still in tutorial?
Wait.
One, two, three.
We almost have...
Four cards.
Wait, four of a kind.
Oh my God, let's go gambling.
Wait, wait.
One, two, three.
Oh, fuck.
Wait.
Okay, if I get rid of...
Okay, I'm gonna get rid of...
I don't need this.
I don't need this, cause...
Wait, I...
I could get...
I'll get another full...
Wait, I could get three, two...
Wait, you're right.
Three, two...
I could get a full house.
Okay.
I got a full house easily.
Plus five, plus five.
Three, two...
Oh my God, I'm learning how to gamble, guys.
So, what's like the bad thing...
Oh, no wonder they try to warn me against gambling.
They're trying to make sure I don't have a good time.
Oh, I got another heart.
That's easy.
Got another heart.
Another flush.
Did I win?
Plus two.
I rode the bus.
Speed up the animation.
Nice.
Alright.
Just don't stop the bus.
Wait, is ace not a face card?
Wait, what does that mean?
Got cash out.
Can I afford this now?
No, I'm still broke.
Oh, if played...
Plus twelve, mult if played, hand contains a straight.
Plus five...
Wait, isn't this good?
Isn't this good?
No?
It's okay.
Straight busted.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Straight bad.
Okay, plus five hand sight reduces by one every round.
What?
Save money?
Okay, I'll save my money.
Situational?
Alright, I'll save my money then.
I'll save my money for the big boys.
J, king, one, two, two, four...
What do I want to get?
I could get...
One, two, three...
Two...
I need to discard some stuff.
I'm gonna discard these.
I'm gonna discard...
I feel like I don't really need these.
I feel like...
Do I discard the face cards?
But like, plus ten!
Oh, my face cards are bad now?
They stopped the...
Sorry, the joker didn't play without scoring?
Okay.
Alright, we discard...
We'll discard the...
We'll ride the bus.
We'll take public transportation.
Oh!
Wait!
I have three!
I have three of a kind!
I just need two!
Do I use three of a kind now or should I...
I could use three of a kind now...
And then get...
Or do I risk it?
I'm gonna pull for full house.
Yeah, I'm gonna pull for full house.
I'm gonna pull for it.
I'm gonna do it.
Let's go gambling.
Okay, I shouldn't have gone gambling, guys.
Alright.
Okay.
I'm so mad!
Alright.
I'll leave.
I'll put...
I'll discard three.
It's okay.
I have two more discards.
Oh, let's go!
Let's fucking go!
I got the plus three multiplier!
Alright.
Okay.
Okay, this is getting a little difficult now.
I got a pair...
And then nothing else.
I have one more discard.
I mean, I could just play the threes for now.
Right?
I have a pair.
I might as well just pull a pair now.
And then, can I...
A pair?
If I play with other cards...
Should I just play the pair now?
And then...
I do...
Oh, wait.
I have double pairs.
So, I have two pairs.
Can I put a discard in?
Or does it really matter?
Chat.
Does it really matter if I have a discard in?
Or can I just put...
Like, should I do it?
I don't know if I should.
Go for Ace's full house?
Guys.
Okay.
Wait.
I could...
I have one more...
I do...
I do have...
You're right.
I have one more discard.
You're so right, guys.
I don't need all these other cards.
I...
You're so right, guys.
Who needs these other cards?
Okay.
Alright.
I guess...
I guess I play this.
Aw, dang it.
I got the multiplier.
Is that enough?
Oh, no.
I need 200 more.
Oh!
Okay, I have a pair.
I think that's fine.
4, 5, 6, 7...
Wait!
Okay, wait.
Can I...
Flush...
4, 5...
5 cards...
Take it straight.
5 cards in a row.
Okay, that's not really it.
Okay, wait.
Wait.
I can do it.
I can do a pair.
I'll just do a pair now.
And then...
Yeah, I don't need much anyway, guys.
I don't need much.
So...
So, it's fine.
I believe in the bus.
That should be it, right?
I got the multiplier.
I'm riding the bus.
Yeah!
I did it!
God, this is such an easy game.
Oh, my God.
Ring Ring Casino?
I'm ready to count my cards.
I'm ready to start counting cards.
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Campbell responsibly.
Brought to you by Doki Steak.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, Anton.
All right.
Cash out.
This is how they hook me in.
This is it.
Permanently gained plus one discard.
Wait, should I buy a voucher?
I feel like Doki just got a...
Marco Rivals, please.
Don't get a discount.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wait, is red card bad?
Oh, wait.
It's red.
Red is always good.
But guys, it's red.
Red is extra special.
For each remaining card in deck currently...
Wait!
How many cards do I have?
I have 52 cards.
Read.
I like how I'm like, guys, I'm not going to read what it does, but it's red.
This joker gains plus three when any booster pack is skipped.
We have more skipping booster packs, so I should get this.
Read.
Mega, choose two of up to four Spectro cards.
What's a Spectro card?
Oh, the Spectro cards are OP?
Say enough.
Alright.
Destroy one random card in your hand and add two random enhanced aces to your cards.
What the fuck?
Add foil holographic or...
Or polychrome effect to one selected card.
Add polychrome to a random joker.
Destroyers converts all hands into a single random rank.
Minus one.
I feel like aura seems like...
Or the aces?
Aces and...
You can add two.
Add poly...
I only have one joker anyway, right?
Oh no, I have two jokers!
Ouija or hex converts all cards to a single random rank.
Destroy ace cards for aces.
I feel like this...
Shouldn't grim be better?
Polychrome?
And destroy...
But...
Rathabus though!
But what if it destroys Rathabus?
It's just a random...
It's just a random card joker!
What if it destroys Rathabus?
How do I sell it?
Is this Jimbo?
They have names?
Who the fuck is Jimbo?
Oh, is he Jimbo?
His name is Joker.
Goodbye, Joker.
Okay, grim and hex.
Wait, I said two, right?
Okay, I'll do hex.
Oh my god, now you're rainbow!
And then ace.
Goodbye, Jimbo.
Wait, and then...
Wait, is Ouija better?
Converts all cards...
Should I get the Ouija or...
Ouija.
Converts all cards in hands to a...
You know I love gambling.
Alright.
Woah.
That's a lot of sevens.
Alright.
Alright, I'm good to go.
You are now...
Oh, is all my cards just sevens now?
Oh my god, lucky seven!
Okay, I'm gonna save my money.
Alright, the window.
All diamond cards are debuffed.
Okay.
Where's my sevens?
Scores no chips, so I'll just get rid of the diamonds then.
Yeah, I'll just get rid of the diamonds.
Oh, you're right!
What if I discard everything until I get sevens?
Let's go gambling.
Oh my god!
Let's go.
Go for all sevens, you're so right.
Two... Oh my god!
Bam, I'm done.
I won.
I won the game.
Holy shit!
155.
The boss, let's go!
Five of a kind.
She's cheating.
She's counting cards!
Not so deadpool, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You can do variety streams on YouTube.
Marble Rivals, Hot Twitch, and silly gambling games on Geek.
The triple threat.
Alright, see you guys on Geek for Poloctro.
Thank you for the super chat.
Not so deadpool, thank you, thank you.
Alright.
Wait, I got another spectral pack!
Wait, I got Voucher.
Appear more frequently.
Okay, wait, I got...
I have 18 dollars.
DNA?
If first hand of round has only one card, add a permanent copy to the deck and draw it to hand.
Alright.
What's this?
If first hand of round is a single six, destroy and create...
Wait, I can create a spectral card!
Is that good?
I can get more sevens!
I can...
Oh my god.
We're here for the seven.
Oh, it's bad.
Should I buy another spectral pack?
Celestia is better?
Oh my god.
I can make more sevens.
Play one seven first round every time.
Oh my god, you're so right.
I can just...
I can just play sevens.
And then my entire deck will just be sevens.
Oh my god, you're so right.
I'll just...
I'll just keep having...
Convert all cards in hand to a single random suit.
Add a purple seal to one selected card.
What's a perk?
Creates a terror card when discarded.
Converts all...
Wait, okay.
If I...
If I do...
Okay, I'm gaming now.
You play the pokies on stream one day?
Okay, medium.
Wait, how do I...
What card do I put?
Do I put it on seven?
Do I get purple seven?
But which seven?
Put the seal on the king?
But I got to ride the bus!
If I...
I can't use face cards, guys!
I can't...
I can't use...
Wait, is that okay?
Oh, but it discards, right?
Oh, it discarded!
Okay, alright.
Are meant to be discarded.
Okay, I'll put it on the king.
Alright, there you go.
Because I have to discard the king, right?
Alright, and then we can buy a celestial pack too.
Because we're rich as fuck.
Alright.
Low up four of a kind.
Low up straight flush.
What's a straight... I'm sorry, I still...
I keep forgetting what...
Wait, four of a kind!
Low up full house.
What was full house again?
Guys?
Wait!
I get four of a kind!
Of sevens!
You're right!
All I just... All I need is seven!
Okay, this is a seven run.
This is actually the seven.
Alright, I'm ready.
I'm fucking ready for the run of the seven.
Alright.
I'll play this.
Has only one card.
Add a permanent...
Okay, if I do this, it'll always be in my deck, right?
Seven, seven, Gamma.
Alright.
Seven.
Oh my god, it's in my deck.
Oh my god.
Easy $144.
Alright, I'm gonna get rid of all these guys.
I don't need you.
I don't fuck you.
Or I could just...
I could get rid of all of these and just get sevens.
Okay, I'll get rid of the five because I don't need the five.
And then...
All I need is just... I'll get rid of the six too because who needs... You don't get rid of all of you guys.
I just need sevens.
The moment I get sevens, I win.
Alright, goodbye.
Goodbye.
I just need one card.
And it's the sevens.
I still... Guys, there's still hope.
There's still hope.
Alright, let's go.
All in.
And not seven.
I discard.
All in.
Let's go.
Actual Exodia deck.
Oh, my easiest game of my life.
Oh, my God.
Alright, cash up.
Alright.
It's time for the sevens.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
I can't believe your first run is the most pilatro run.
Wait.
What do you mean negative?
No money?
Negative jokers are free?
I broke the game?
I can't afford it?
No!
Why did I buy the celestial pack?
Why?
No!
Wait, if I sell DNA...
Guys, do I do it?
Do I sell DNA?
Do I?
No, don't.
Guys, I don't need DNA.
Do not.
But, plus two chips for each remaining card in deck.
No, I need a five.
DNA is much better.
I'll see you again.
Don't worry.
I'll see you again, don't worry.
Alright, here we go again.
Here we go.
Here we go again.
Wait, I got four of a kind.
Is it four of a kind?
I forgot.
I forgot to do a single seven.
No, I forgot to do a single seven.
Wait, no!
Can I still do it?
Can I still play that one seven?
Oh, I can.
Oh, good.
Alright.
I'll clone this one.
Okay.
I'm gonna clone this one.
Alright.
Nice.
I got another seven.
Okay, do I...
Should I do the full?
I do have four of a kind multiplier.
I don't remember the four of a kind multiplier.
Or should I do fives?
Just for five of a kind.
Try four of a kind.
Okay, four of a kind is better.
Okay.
Check run info.
But I have the four of a kind level two.
Oh, but it's 120x12.
Wait, that's bigger numbers.
You're right.
The numbers are bigger.
You're right, I still have hope.
Wait, discard.
Creates a random...
Oh, but that's too huge.
Can I...
Oh, no.
This is so risky.
Come on.
I got...
Oh, my...
Let's go gambling!
What the fuck is...
What the fuck is this?
Holy shit.
Okay.
Let's play this one.
Oh, my God.
Even better.
Alright.
Yeah, guys, you think I won?
Seven sevens.
I'm a natural.
Casinos, watch out.
Don't keep...
It's gonna be banned from all casinos from here on out.
Alright.
How about Flush 5?
Wait, Flush 5?
Wait!
This is so good!
Oh, my God.
I'll sell the tower.
And then, let me get...
Let me get Flush 5.
Wait, do I do buy and use?
Buy and...
What's the difference between buy and use?
No, just...
Buy and use, right?
Okay, buy and use.
Let's fucking go!
Alright.
One in two chances to get a tower caught when any booster pack is open.
Oh, no.
If I get that, should I save my money?
Uh, let's see.
Always caught.
What a silly run.
What?
Why is she...
Okay, buy Mega Arcane.
Is Mega Arcane actually worth it?
Save?
I don't know.
Is it worth it?
This is my first run.
What do you mean?
It's just sevens!
I just...
Okay, next round.
I'm just trying...
I'm just doing sevens.
I don't know what you...
Alright.
Wait, I'll just put this one now.
I can clone it now.
I'll clone it now, actually.
Uh...
No?
It's over?
Why?
Wait, what?
How is it over?
Why?
There's no heart.
There's no seven.
Clone hearts?
There's no hearts!
Hearts are debuffed?
Oh.
Heart cards are debuffed.
Oh, okay.
Okay, we'll clone this.
I got the clubs now.
Alright.
Although all my sevens are hearts, you're right.
It's possible.
We're fine.
Discard.
Okay.
It's not over yet.
One, two, three, four.
Discard.
Guys, we're...
Oh no.
It's my...
It's my last discard, guys.
It's my last one.
Oh
no.
Okay.
Plus seven.
Twenty -four.
Thirty-six.
Five thousand!
I made it!
I actually...
Ah, see?
No losses yet.
We're cleared.
We're so back.
Oh my god.
It is the...
It is the seven run.
Oh my god.
The run of the seven.
Wait.
What is this?
Retriggered all play cards and final hand a round?
Wait, I can get so many sevens!
Wait, plus one hand size!
Wait, I can get so many.
Wait, get the voucher.
You're right, you're right.
Another hand.
Oh my god.
But imagine how many sevens I could get.
Imagine if I had this Joker.
Just how many sevens I could use.
Choose up to...
Oh, I don't know.
These are regular booster packs.
I feel like regular booster packs is possibly...
Yeah, I'm gonna save my money.
You could get a seven.
Look for a seven there.
Yeah, but then...
My money.
I could save my money though.
Guys.
The booster pack can contain a seven.
You're so right.
Oh, never mind.
Never mind.
Skip.
Next round.
It's not a seven.
We don't want that.
How do I have no sevens?
That's absolutely crazy.
I got zero sevens.
That's so fucking crazy.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Oh, no.
Guys, this is looking grim.
Oh, wait.
Okay, we're gonna... Do I clone the hearts or the spades?
I know I cloned a lot of other sevens.
Like, which...
Which seven should I clone?
Clone seven of hearts?
Hearts, okay.
Play hand.
Yay, I got another seven.
Yay!
More sevens!
Okay, and then we get rid of everything else.
Alright.
Discard.
Guys, this is not looking so great.
Guys.
Guys, I'm a little worried.
I only have three sevens, guys.
I'm...
I'm a little worried.
Okay.
My last one.
Come on.
Come on, baby.
Get me that...
No!
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
We can have four sevens.
Do I win with four?
Plus seven, plus seven, plus seven.
X24.
X36.
4000.
Oh, this is so risky.
No, and then it gives me a seven!
Oh,
no.
Oh, no.
Oh.
I'll just play off.
Oh, no.
Wait.
Not like this.
Five, six.
But I lose my bus.
Try two pairs.
Oh, no.
Oh.
I'll run the pair.
Play your junk cards to fish for more sevens.
You're right.
I'll do pairs.
And then five twos.
Okay, okay.
We'll do this.
I need to keep that seven.
I need to keep the seven.
No, if I do this, I lose my bus.
We need the bus.
Wait, does the face doesn't count?
No, it does!
Doesn't it count?
It won't trigger if I place this?
Oh, it counts.
Okay.
Okay, it counts.
Alright, we'll do this.
Oh, okay.
I'm gonna do this.
Okay, plus 22.
X17.
It's a bus time.
Oh, I won anyway.
It doesn't matter.
I won anyway.
Oh, that scared me a little bit.
That scared...
Oh, I thought the seven run was gone.
Oh, that scared me just a little bit.
Never punish.
Let's go.
The dawn of the seven.
Play cards with hard suit game plus three.
Wait.
I always play...
Wait, double the money?
Wait, is it doubles money?
Maximum of 20.
Wait.
Wait, I can double the money.
I want the hermit.
Okay, hermit.
But then I also...
Guys, but I also get...
I also play cards a lot.
Oh my God.
We have $28 now.
Do I get this?
It said, yes, get the jewel.
Oh my God, you're right.
It's red.
It should be good.
Let's go.
Alright.
Should I get any packs?
Which pack do I get?
The jumbo or the buffoon pack?
Buffoon?
Put this guy on the left side?
Why?
What's wrong with that?
Buffoon is better.
Alright, I'm rich anyway.
I'm fucking rich as hell.
What's the...
It played...
Hand contains a flesh.
What's a flesh?
I always keep forgetting what a flesh is.
Like...
Oh, let's share the same...
Oh, wait.
Wait, is that good?
Suit changes every round.
Yeah, I should get the flesh face, right?
Castle is good because you discard all the time.
I do discard a lot.
Oh, this is difficult.
A flesh 5.
Yeah, but like...
It's so risky.
Am I really gonna get all hearts, though?
Am I...
I feel like...
I get more discards than hearts.
Yeah, I'm gonna do castle.
I discard more.
I feel like.
Yeah, alright.
Here we go.
Next round.
Oh my god, okay.
Okay.
I'll clone the...
The spade.
I'll copy the spade.
Let's go.
Fire, right?
Okay, okay.
I'm gonna...
Oh, dupe.
No, the clone the...
Sorry, the club.
I'll clone the club.
Or the heart?
Oh, you're right!
Because I have the heart!
You're so right.
Almost forgot.
I got a plus 3 multiplier.
Oh, castle to the far left?
Okay.
Far left, castle.
Alright.
And then...
I'll just discard these guys.
And then I'll get...
I'll get 5 sevens.
Alright.
I'm gonna mine...
7 sevens now.
Alright, sevens.
2, 4, okay.
It's not a 7.
I don't care.
Don't care.
Alright, here we go.
There we go.
Bam!
All the sevens in the world!
Let's go!
Alright!
I win.
What is this deck?
It's my special 7 deck.
It's my lucky deck, guys.
I'm building...
I'm building my lucky deck.
Let's go!
Alright.
Every time a playing card is added to your deck.
And...
$2 per discard.
If no discards are used by...
Oh, wait.
I always use discard, though.
Hologram?
The Joker gains...
Every time a playing card is...
Wait, is that good?
I guess it's good.
I don't know what it does, but okay.
I believe you guys.
Alright.
The Joker gains...
0.25...
Every time a playing card is added to your deck.
Has only one card added.
Okay, cool.
Alright.
Okay.
Let's see.
Celestial to upgrade?
Should I get Celestial or Arcane, guys?
Buy Arcane?
You're so good with this.
This is my first run.
This is literally my first run.
I don't know.
I just happened to get...
I just happened...
Oh my god, it has one...
Select a card and...
Increases rank of up to two selected cards.
Wait, I can increase my two!
I can increase my seven rank!
Wait, do I get...
Oh my god, they're so good!
Magician?
And has two selected cards, so lucky.
Wait.
Oh, it changes them to eight?
Oh!
Okay, I get it.
Wait, if I do Magician...
And I make my sevens lucky...
One in five chance for a...
Plus 20 multiplier?
One in 15...
Oh my god, a plus 20 multiplier?
Oh my god.
Oh!
Hang to eliminate...
Wait, okay.
Do I...
Okay, but multiplier is better, right?
If I get lucky sevens?
Oh my, wait, I can just...
I can just make my sevens so fucking lucky.
Oh my god, I don't know.
Do I...
Do I destroy my non-seven cards?
Or make...
Oh my god, do it.
I can make it so lucky.
Guys, it's a plus 20 multiplier.
Better sevens or kill lower cards?
Yes, but I will go...
Hangman means more sevens though, you're so right.
You're so fucking right.
I could literally have more sevens.
Oh, you're so right.
Wait, but then I can clone...
Guys, but then I can clone my lucky cards.
I can clone my lucky...
The lucky cards never...
Oh, the luck has a low chance of hitting?
Alright, say less.
Goodbye, four and five.
Give me my sevens.
I need my sevens.
Alright.
Jumbo Celestial Pack.
Okay, I open.
Level up two pairs.
Plus one.
Level up full house.
Level up pair.
Oh my god, I level up a Flush.
Five cards.
Oh wait, no.
What about upgrade?
They're all pretty fucking bad, not gonna lie.
Not gonna...
Not gonna lie.
Aeris?
Level up Flush five?
But when am I gonna get a Flush five?
You really think I'm gonna get a Flush five?
Really?
Alright.
Trust?
You're right.
It's all about gambling.
You're so right, guys.
Seven hearts.
Think of the seven hearts, Doki.
Think of it.
All club cards are debuffed.
Okay, don't worry.
I have hearts.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
Okay, I'm gonna clone.
I'm gonna clone more sevens.
I'm gonna...
Let me...
Let me clone my sevens.
My...
Let me clone my hearts real quick.
I'm gonna clone my hearts.
Alright, plus one.
And I got the plus three.
And I got the plus six.
And I got the plus 1.5.
Fucking easy.
Alright.
And I'll discard the non-sevens.
Uh...
Cause like, it's debuffed, so like...
I don't get anything, so I might as well...
Oh, discard.
I'm gonna...
Yeah, I'm gonna use my discard first.
And then, I'm gonna keep using my discard.
No, I can still use this.
I can still use this.
But like...
If I play it, it doesn't count.
Play it?
Do I play it now?
But the debuff...
Just play them?
Okay.
I almost played the eight.
Bro, the eight.
Okay.
I don't know.
I'll discard first.
Maybe I'll be lucky.
Maybe I'll get like, two more hearts.
Wait, no, but then I don't have...
No, but then I don't have like, space for... Wait, I could.
I could technically get...
I could technically... Okay, I'm gonna discard first.
I'm gonna discard first.
Oh my god.
Okay, this is a little unlucky right now.
Okay, I'm still gonna discard.
I'm gonna discard still.
If I discard this, I could get another seven.
One, two, three, four.
Oh my god, if I could get another...
I could get another seven.
Oh my god.
Wait, okay.
Wait, I could get a non-debuff seven though.
The green is already settling in.
Okay, what if I play this now and then... I could play this now though.
I...
I couldn't.
Okay, I'm gonna play it.
I'm gonna play it.
Oh, but then if I discard, I can get more castles.
I'm gonna do it.
I could get more sevens, guys.
It's fine.
I got the castle.
I got plus 19.
I got plus 1.5.
I already won.
Alright.
Alright, I don't need to play more cards.
It's alright.
Cash out time.
Yay!
Oh my god, I can destroy more cards that aren't seven!
Does nothing?
Wait, I can level up a straight flush.
What's a straight flush again?
I keep having to check.
Oh my god, another hangman.
I can buy nothing.
Wait.
How do I use it?
How do I fucking use it now?
Oh, and then there's a celestial.
Celestial.
Oh, I can use it later?
Oh, in the round.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
I have 17 dollars.
Is it worth buying?
Okay, buffoon pack or celestial pack chat?
DavidB7.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, save money.
Alright, I can do that.
Okay.
It says it does nothing.
Chat.
I'm not gonna buy nothing.
I'm not.
Guys, I'm not gonna.
But is it really nothing?
It's paid off.
I'm not gonna.
I'm not gonna buy 10 of them.
Unlocks a plus one joker.
Alright, alright, fine.
Are you sure it's worth it?
Alright.
Alright, I'll invest.
I'll invest, guys.
I'm feeling particularly lucky today.
Alright.
I'm good to go.
Where's my sevens?
Okay, I'm gonna clone this seven.
What?
I just...
What do you mean I didn't listen to you guys?
What do you mean?
Why not four?
I listened to you guys.
Alright.
Let's get rid of all these other filthy cards.
One, two, three.
Alright.
Get out of here.
Oh, destroy the cards?
Oh, I forgot to destroy them!
No!
Okay, we'll do that next time.
Guys, we'll do that next time.
Guys, we'll do it next time, guys.
One, two, three, four, five.
Oh, nice.
I can still discard.
I'll just keep getting sevens.
Yeah, but like, they're not...
Wait, can I...
How do I use it?
Oh, do I destroy these guys?
Can I just destroy these guys?
Oh, only destroy faces.
Okay.
Okay, I will...
I'll destroy faces then.
That's JQueenKing, right?
Is that JQueenKing?
Face cards?
Alright, I'm gonna destroy... I'm gonna discard these guys first, so I can get the seven multiplier.
So I can get the castle multiplier.
Discard.
Yay, upgrade!
Ooh, alright.
Discard.
Yay, upgrade!
Oh, and then I can destroy these.
Use.
Okay.
Goodbye.
Alright.
Now I have... five!
Five sevens!
That's right!
Give me my multiplier!
That's fucking right!
And then my castle and the boss and the plus one point fifty thousand!
Fuck it!
Alright.
Burn, baby, burn!
Alright,
nice.
This is pretty easy.
It's just...
It's just that easy.
Oh...
I have... Well, I got...
Save?
Arcana pack?
Choose one of up to be used in me... I would wait?
If I buy the devil and...
Oh, if this card is held in hand...
Three dollars, this card is held in hand in the round.
You get more money if you get to twenty-five gold?
Really?
Oh, I like the sound of that.
I'll save.
I can save.
Alright.
What do I have?
Ooh, clone!
Alright, play hand.
Give me my sevens!
That's fucking right.
Give me my sevens.
Mr. Wade, give the five, give the six, thank you.
That's fucking right.
Give me my sevens.
Thank you.
Alright, two...
Okay, get rid of these guys.
Okay, plus three chest per discarded heart.
Alright.
Okay.
Alright, and then I get rid of you guys, too.
And then...
A single seven scored 2.6k.
The power of the sevens!
That's fucking right.
Oh, I got...
Select two cards, convert the left card into the right... what?
The fuck does that mean?
Alright, I gotta discard these guys.
Wait, what does this mean?
Do I save this?
Oh my god, I can convert into a seven?!
Wait, I'm gonna save that.
I don't need that.
I don't need that yet.
I'm gonna save it.
Because I know I'm gonna reach...
I know I can get it.
I...
No, but like...
Why?!
I can save it.
Wait, is it permanent?
Save it?
Oh, save it for a face card.
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Oh, it's permanent?
Yeah, I don't need it yet.
I don't need it yet.
I'd rather do it for... it's a permanent change.
Okay, wait.
Convert the left card into the right.
So if I...
Oh!
I'm gonna save it for a face.
You're right.
Yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna save it.
Alright, I need more sevens.
Okay, that's good enough.
But if I discard these two, I can get... I can get a fifth seven of hearts!
Guys!
If I discard these two, I might get a fifth!
Okay, I'm gonna discard these two.
I could get... Oh, mock!
It's fine.
This works.
I got four.
I got... It's fine.
This is good enough.
This is actually good enough.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
Nice.
And then I got another plus three.
And then another one.
And then plus thirty-six.
Plus twenty-three.
Next one, hundred.
Okay, I got twenty-six thousand dollars.
Oh, nice.
I could have had a flush.
Guys, we should be happy.
I even made it this far.
Whoa!
Play cards with Aura and skip plus twenty.
Guys!
Seven is in!
Oh my god!
Seven is in there!
I gotta get it!
Wait, do I have to sell?
Should I sell the castle?
Wait, but does it... Does it build up?
Oh, sell the castle.
Okay.
I'll sell you.
Oh, does that... does that go up?
Oh, for each seven!
Oh my... Goodbye, castle.
You were good to me.
You were so good to me, but right now, I need seven.
I need seven!
Okay.
Alright.
Move it to the far left here.
Reorganize your joker.
Okay, joker order.
That should be five.
Do I... Should I save or... Oh, flush five.
I don't know if I'll get a flush five, though.
It's freaking rare as hell.
It's so rare.
Oh.
Alright, buy and use.
Okay, I'll buy and use.
I trust you guys.
I trust you.
Okay.
Alright, you're building a flush five.
Alright.
I think I can go to the...
Do I take the arcana pack, too?
Oh, I can...
Oh, it'll pay off.
Okay.
Should I save or go for the arcana pack, guys?
Arcana's...
Hmm...
Ahhh...
Save.
I'm gonna save.
Alright, what's the next one?
Kai's drawn face down after each hand... What?
Oh.
Okay.
Alright, this is getting scary now.
This is getting real scary now.
Wow.
I can still discard, right?
I'm gonna discard first.
Yeah, I'm gonna discard four hearts so I can clone it.
Okay, two, four, five.
Okay.
Discard.
Oh my god.
Yes!
My seven!
Hahaha!
Yes!
Okay.
This is so dumb.
Oh yeah!
Okay.
So I can turn these two into seven.
Oh wait, turn your left card into the right card.
So all I do is put this...
and then I'll do that.
Wait, turn your left card into the right card and then I do that.
There we go.
Is that not how you arrange it?
It's the left card to the right card.
No?
Oh!
Wait, but it says...
Wait, what?
I'm confused.
Do I do this and then I do this?
Oh!
Is that how it works?
Is that it?
I'm a little confused.
Oh, okay.
Become a seven!
Hahaha!
And thus, you shall become a seven!
One, two, okay.
Alright, get out of here.
You're not a seven.
One, two, three, four, five.
Alright, let's go.
Hahaha!
Let's go!
One, two, three, four, five.
Alright, get in here.
Two, four, alright.
And thus, the seven.
The seven deck is made again.
There we go.
One, six, five.
One, nine, six.
Oh, it's still going up.
Woah!
It's still going up!
56,982!
Guys, you think I got $22,000 yet?
You think I got...
Hahaha!
Oh, the numbers.
What are they saying?
Hahaha!
What do the numbers mean, guys?
What do the numbers mean?
Hahaha!
Buy the Voucher?
Minus one ante, minus one hand?
Wait, are you sure?
But it says minus one.
Yeah, I'm not kidding.
It feels like the Voucher.
I'm gonna save.
I don't think I need any of these.
Yeah.
I don't think I need any packs.
You're only playing two hands per round.
I feel like...
Okay, I'll do Arcana pack.
Alright, what kind of good packs are there?
Wait, I can make more sevens!
Hahaha!
Okay, wait.
Guys, I can make more sevens!
Guys!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, I can make...
Hahaha!
Oh my god!
I can make another seven!
Hahaha!
Queen into seven.
Okay, I'm sliding to the right card.
Alright, there you go.
Good move.
This is right.
This is it, right?
Left to right.
Okay, convert the left card.
Okay, there you go.
And thus...
You shall become a seven!
Hahaha!
Alright, next round.
Alright, let's go.
Alright.
Let's get rid of all these non-fuck...
Okay, wait.
First off, we use the clone first.
So we get another seven.
And then...
After that...
Alright, plus three, multiply.
Plus ten, plus twenty-six.
Next one.
Oh my god.
Let's go.
Oh, now it's five thousand.
Wow!
And then we get rid of these guys.
Uh, cause you're not a seven.
And then one, two, three, four, five.
You know what?
Let's just try and get...
Three more hearts.
Uh...
Hahaha!
Let's just...
Let's just get three more hearts.
Like, you know?
It doesn't matter.
Actually, it doesn't really matter about discards anymore.
Like...
I feel like discards don't matter cause I don't have a castle anyway.
So like, who fucking cares?
I'll just fucking play the card.
Like...
Here we go.
But...
Let's go.
Yeah, no castle.
Here we go.
Yeah!
Woo!
But what about the flush five, donkey?
Think about the...
Think about the adrenaline you're gonna get when you get a plus...
Plus five.
The card to give you plus three...
Plus two chips each...
For each remaining card in deck.
Currently a hun...
No, I don't need...
Oh, there's a mega celestial pack?
And a jumbo celestial pack?
Oh, there are...
Okay, I wanna get the mega.
Not worth?
Is it really not worth?
Is it really?
What the fuck?
Mega!
Mega the next round?
Oh, it is worth?
Okay, I'm gonna do it.
Mega pack.
Choose two.
Level up pair...
Level up hide card?
What the fuck is a hide card?
The player has only the highest rank card scores.
Okay.
Level up flush?
Level up straight flush?
Level up four of a kind?
Let's see.
A hide card is one.
Wait.
Wait, is it just one card?
That's just one card, right?
Level up four of a kind.
Level up straight flush.
I keep forgetting what straight flush is.
I always have to fucking look at it.
Pluto and Mars.
Oh!
Level up four of a kind.
Oh, that's true.
I'm gonna get Pluto first because it's like one.
Okay, because it's the DNA, right?
Yeah, DNA.
It's for the sevens.
You're so right.
Yeah, for the sevens.
If I'm desperate, I can get four of a kind.
But then like...
If I do straight flush...
Okay, not straight flush, but...
Was it just a flush?
I could have...
All sevens with...
Then what if I have all sevens with...
We have sevens.
You're right, four of a kind.
Oh, the multiplayer is bigger.
Oh, wait.
Wait, but the multiplayer is bigger for four of a kind versus like...
Yeah, four is better.
You're right, guys.
Four is so much better.
Alright.
We're good to go.
Next round.
Let's go.
Oh my God.
Let's keep making my hearts.
Let's go.
Let's keep...
Alright.
No, we got it.
I'm getting my sevens first, guys.
I'm getting my sevens.
Let's go.
It's calling to us.
The sevens are calling to us.
Chat.
Nice.
Alright, and then we get rid of these guys.
Goodbye.
Oh, I need to sell the tower, right?
Wonderful.
Okay.
I won.
Nice.
Oh my God, look at the numbers.
It keeps going up.
500x, 200x, 400x.
Let's go.
Speed up, please.
No, I like to see it go.
I like...
Oh, a standard pack.
Oh my God.
I could get a seven in a standard pack.
I should sell the tower, right?
Numbers go up.
Highway Tech, thank you for the magenta super.
For your very first super.
Thank you.
Alright.
I could get more sevens.
You're so right.
Wait, what's a steel card?
While this card stays in hand?
Buy a standard...
And check the card pile on the bottom.
7777.
Should I sell the tower, chat?
Alright, I sell the tower.
And then I buy...
The chariot.
So, as long as...
I don't...
What's a steel card, though?
What does a steel card mean?
See, thank you for the 7777, super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Chariot for non...
Don't buy...
I don't know what the chariot is.
Steal a seven that's not a heart?
You keep it to get 1.5?
Or do I just not use it?
If I don't use it, it'll always give me a 1.5 multiplier, right?
7777.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, I'll buy the...
I'm fucking rich anyway.
I'll buy the chariot.
Fuck it.
And then I'll buy the standard pack.
I might get a seven.
I might... YES!
Let's go!
Let's fucking go!
Oh my god.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Wait, why do I get the four when I could get the seven?
Seven!
But it's not seven though!
It's not a seven!
Okay, oh, as long as I don't discard this.
Oh, you're right.
If I don't discard it...
Oh my god, I don't know.
A steel stack?
But then like, I can't discard it though.
Guys, I can't discard it!
I need more cards to discard!
We gotta get the sevens.
Steel is a seven of hearts and cop.
Yeah, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna get the seven.
But the seven!
We need more sevens!
I don't care!
I need more sevens.
I need more sevens in my deck.
No repeat hand type.
No repeat hand types this round.
Wait, what does that mean?
What does no repeat hand types this round?
Wait!
Wait, does that mean I can't use sevens anymore?
I can one-shot it!
Guys, I can one-shot it!
I can one-shot it, guys!
Alright, we'll play...
I can play one...
I only have to play one seven.
And then...
It's fine.
I play one seven.
That's fine, it works.
Oh, I forgot to steal it!
No!
I forgot to steal it.
Alright, it's fine.
I'll steal it later.
I don't need to steal it yet.
Do I really need to steal a seven?
I want to put these guys away first.
I'm going to discard these guys first.
Yeah, I'll do it next time.
I'm not desperate enough.
Okay, I'll get rid of all these guys first.
And then I get...
Give the total sell value of all...
Fucking, I don't need that.
One, two, three, four, five.
Okay, I won.
I won.
One, two, three, four.
Alright.
Free money.
Use the total sell value of all...
I can do this whenever.
Wait, do I use it now?
Steal the non-hard sell...
No?
Doesn't it sell my stuff?
Use the total sell value of all...
Current Joker?
No?
Oh, it's free money?
Oh, okay.
I like free money.
Yay, alright.
I don't need to steal it yet.
I'm fucking...
It's already won.
Yay.
How much is my stack?
Alright, plus 10, plus 31, plus...
Nice.
We won.
Alright.
See guys, I don't...
Don't steal this.
Cash out.
Wow.
Plus 20 money is 4 per round.
Re-roll boss blind one time per ante.
$10 per roll.
I can get more 7s.
Wait, is that...
That's good, yeah.
So I don't have to worry about...
If it's a bad...
I can do it.
I'm gonna buy this voucher.
I'm fucking rich anyway.
And I'm gonna buy another for more 7s.
Okay, alright.
Okay, I'll...
I'll increase the speed by 2.
I'll...
Okay, and then...
I can get another 7.
What the fuck?
No rank or suit?
What's that mean?
Stone cart?
But I'm gonna skip.
Yeah, I'm gonna skip.
That's not a 7.
You know, I have enough money to do another one.
C'mon, give me a 7.
Wait, what?
Ace foil cart.
I don't need that.
That's not a 7.
Get out of here.
You're not a 7.
I'm gonna throw you away anyway.
Get out.
Alright.
Alright, let's go.
Next round.
Alright.
Skip.
Alright, nice.
Oh my God, let's play.
Alright, 7.
And then I get a free 7.
Let's go.
Okay, so...
What do I steal?
Nah, it's fine.
We don't need to steal.
I'm just gonna keep it here.
I'm gonna...
I want to...
Wait, but I could get two hearts.
I'm greedy.
I'm so greedy.
Okay, I'm not greedy anymore.
I'm not greedy anymore.
I'm not.
I'll steal it when I need it.
When I'm desperate, chat.
I'm not desperate yet.
Not yet.
We don't need it yet.
I don't need to.
I'm not desperate enough.
Converts up to 3 selected cards.
No, I don't need clubs.
Each face card held in hand has a 1 in chance to give you $1.
Oh, it's a joker card.
I don't need that.
What the fuck is going on?
What the...
You steal the card you're about to copy so you can get a bunch of...
Yeah, but doesn't it stay...
Oh, okay.
You can steal the card you're about to copy so you can get a bunch of steel.
Oh.
Okay, I'll do that next time.
Buy both packs?
Arcana?
Okay, I'll do arcana.
Alright, I'm rich anyway, so it doesn't matter.
Oh my god, I can destroy...
I can keep destroying.
Wait, I can keep this...
Wait, I can convert this into a 7.
Wait,
I can enhance.
Wait, I can empress my 7 of hearts.
Wait!
I can put multipliers on my 7s!
Let's fucking go!
I can make my 7s even better!
Let's go!
Okay.
Do it.
Empress 7 are destroyed.
I'm gonna enhance my 7s.
I can have a plus 4 multiplier.
It's even better.
Oh my god, I can clone them.
You're so right!
I can clone my 7s and then have all my...
I can have them all!
Alright, you're right.
That's right.
Torn in top, beautiful 7s.
I might as well buy this.
I'm fucking rich anyway.
Alright.
4 of a kind?
Oh my god, I can...
Continue to level my 4 of a kind!
My super 7s!
Alright.
Okay, this game is too fast.
Don't you show your deck.
It must look funny.
4 of a kind, baby!
Alright, let's see our deck after this.
I'm actually curious.
Oh my god!
My god!
Oh, the 7s!
It's just...
28 7s!
Oh my god.
Okay, next round!
Next round!
More 7s than...
Oh my god!
Wait, okay, if I do this...
Wait, how do I... can I use it?
Do I do that?
Can I steal this?
No?
Not this?
Which one do I steal?
Oh, it overwrites?
Oh, okay, I won't steal it.
Okay, I'll just use this.
I'll just play this to get another clone.
Now I have 29.
Alright guys, now I have 29... 7 of hearts.
Oh, should I steal the club?
Alright.
Steal a black... well, I already copied it, so I can't.
I'll do it later.
I'll do it one day.
I'll steal it one day.
Alright, I won.
1, 2, 3, 4.
Alright.
It's over already.
Oh, nice.
Alright.
The club.
Why?
Oh my god, there's a mega.
Oh my god, there's a mega standard pack.
Wait, I can buy both.
I'm gonna buy both.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna... I can buy two sevens.
Think of all the sevens I can buy.
Wait, these are pretty bad, not gonna lie.
Not gonna lie.
These are okay.
Straight flush, two pair, full house.
I might as well get Uranus, yeah.
No, I mean, I might as well get the three of a kind.
Yeah, these all suck.
Yeah, I'll get three of a kind though.
Three of a kind is the best one.
Alright, and now I can buy two sevens.
There it is.
There you are.
Alright, and then I'll leave.
Wait, that's a wild card?
Yeah, I'm gonna skip it.
Alright, there we go.
Next round.
First hand is drawn face down?
What does that mean?
Discard!
You're right.
I'm gonna discard one card.
Wait, I'll discard one card.
And then we'll see how it goes.
Restore it by rank.
No, discard five?
But what if I discard a seven?!
Guys!
What if I discard a seven?!
Seven!
No, you have so many.
Fine!
Discard them all.
I'll discard them all.
You have two ten thousand.
Oh, you're right.
I can steal it.
Wait, why won't it let me steal?
It won't let me do it.
Huh?
Oh, I have three select.
Oh wait, when the fuck did I have these guys selected?
Okay, I'm gonna steal this guy and then I'll copy it.
A non-seven?
Wait, I don't know.
Do I steal a non-seven or a seven?
I don't know.
Steal a seven and dupe?
But it only works if I don't play the seven.
Oh!
Okay, I will never play a queen, so I'll steal a queen.
So I get the 1.5 multiplier.
I don't know.
No?
I don't understand.
Me no understand.
I don't understand!
Brain hurt!
Oh, I already won.
Let me copy this real quick though.
Let me... Let me copy this real quick.
You want seven?
You're trying to limit all the cards that aren't... but not use that.
Stealing, you can use if you're in a pinch.
Steal?
Okay, I'm gonna steal it.
Okay, I'll steal it.
Or do I steal the diamond?
I'll steal... Okay, I'll steal the diamond...
And then... And then I'll copy it.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'm gonna steal the diamond.
And then...
Play the diamond card.
And then throw these guys away.
And then I have five.
And then... Alright.
And then I'll get the...
And then I got $336,000.
And then...
And that's how... That's how it goes.
That's how it goes here.
Up to two selected cards by one?
I can make more sevens.
Reroll costs $2 less.
Should I get the Jumbo Arcana pack?
I might as well get the Jumbo Arcana pack.
So much money.
Uh... Double money?
One in four chance to add to a random joker.
It's up to two.
It's up to two random planet cards.
Is that two cards?
Wait, I can make more sevens.
Wait.
Does it make it better?
Does it make my...
I can make more sevens.
Oh, I can use strength.
Okay.
I'll use strength on...
Six.
Yeah, I'm gonna increase it on the six.
So it becomes a seven.
Seven is the correct thing.
Okay.
Yeah, but then, like, wouldn't... That wouldn't turn into a seven though.
Alright, I'll do it.
Now you shall become a seven.
And then I'll destroy you too.
But like, what if I don't get it?
Guys.
Will?
Does it... Can it give me a shitty... Can it give me a shitty outcome, chat?
No?
The worst is... Oh, the worst is nothing happened.
Let's gamble!
Oh my God!
Okay.
Alright, let's move... Open this arcana pack too.
Let's go!
Two converts up to three.
Creates the last.
Use during this run.
Wait, I can get another wheel?
Let's spin!
Oh, okay, nevermind.
I didn't... I didn't get... I didn't get lucky again.
That's fine.
I don't need it again.
Alright.
There we go.
Nice.
Nope.
That's fine.
I don't need it.
I didn't need it at all.
Alright, goodbye.
Goodbye.
Oh, I could get more.
Oh my God!
Do I... Oh, I'll steal you.
Wait, no.
I have to get another copy though.
I don't have a copy yet, guys.
Nope!
I wanna wait until I get a copy!
I don't have a copy!
I don't have a copy though!
Yeah.
I'll just... I'll do 4 of a kind.
Like, I feel like...
I have a level 4 4 of a kind, so I...
I feel like... I feel like...
Oh wait, what's my multi... Oh yeah, my multiplier is better.
4 of a kind.
Yeah, I'm just gonna get 4 of a kind.
I have a fucking x4 4 of a kind.
Alright, nice.
4 is better than 5.
Let's go.
Yeah!
Cash out!
Contains plus 2.
Alright.
Jumbo... Jumbo Celestial pack!
Let's open!
Oh my God!
Another flush 5!
Let's go!
Level up 3 of a kind.
Level up a high card.
Oh, but I can level up a high card.
Wait.
Pluto though.
I always do Pluto.
Guys, do I do... Guys, I can't... I don't know!
I always play Pluto every time!
Pluto!
I always do Pluto!
Yeah, I think high card is better.
I always do Pluto anyway.
But big number!
No, I think Pluto is because I always do Pluto, so it's fine.
7!
What?
We trigger this card?
No.
Fuck that shit.
Next round.
It's not 7.
I don't care.
Alright, nice.
I'll steal... Oh, I got this steal.
Nice.
I'll... Let me... I need to clone this.
Sorry, I'm not stealing it because I need to clone this real quick.
I... I need... I need... I need to... I need to clone this real quick.
Alright, nice.
And then I just win.
Wait.
Oh, wait, wait.
I got to discard this first.
Let me discard these two so I can get... Oh my god!
I get another...
Wait, I get another... Wait!
Let's fucking go!
I get another Pluto!
I'm using the Pluto.
No, I'm not.
I don't care.
I like a Pluto and then I win.
Let's go.
Yay!
Never punished.
Never pu... She is going to win a Pluto.
Wait, I can get books!
Sevens!
Let's go!
Oh my god.
Okay, no.
I don't need these.
Okay, I have so much money that I'm just going to open packs until I get a seven.
No.
Skip.
Alright, what's my deck like?
What is it?
I have 34.
Probability-wise, I think I got this.
Should I re-roll?
I can re-roll.
I don't mind.
Check the half-joker.
Plus 20 multi-up played hand contains three or few...
Oh my god, Jesus.
Wait, I can... You know what?
Fuck it.
Let's re-roll.
Level up straight.
Adds the number of times poker hand has been played this run.
Level up... Wait, re-roll.
Oh, wait.
I should have bought the voucher.
Fuck it.
Whatever.
I feel like I don't really need... Oh, it's too late.
I feel like I don't really need it.
Level up straight.
Oh, it's straight again.
I feel like I never used it so I keep forgetting.
Oh, I don't need it.
I'll just buy a voucher.
I'm so fucking rich.
I don't really care anymore.
Alright, skip.
Skip all.
Replace it with space?
Pump the DNA.
He's been with me for so long.
Guys, he's been with me for so long.
Skip all.
Yeah, I want DNA's better.
Oh, shit.
One random joker disabled every hand.
Oh, no.
Re-roll?
How do I re-roll this?
Re-roll boss?
Do I tank those?
It's fine.
It should be fine.
I have so many insane multipliers.
I don't think it really matters.
Because it's one random joker, right?
Yeah.
Bro, I have like... I have so many jokers.
I'm fine with that.
Alright, okay.
I just don't use the hearts.
It's that easy.
I'll discard all these guys.
And then... I'll build this.
Woah, woah, woah, woah.
I'll just make a copy now because I'm worried it's gonna do... Yeah.
I'll copy this and then I'll be fine.
I'm gonna clone this right now.
Play flesh 5, win?
Yeah, but if I play this and then like... I just disable... I get this undisabled and then... Oh, I just play and I win?
Okay.
No, just win.
Like, I don't care.
Just win the game.
I did it.
Alright, that was great.
That was my first... That was literally my first time playing and I won the game.
Oh my god.
Yay!
Guys, wow.
I thought this... Wait, I thought this game was supposed to be alright.
Keep it.
Now keep going.
Guys, if I keep going, we'll never stop.
We're never gonna stop.
I feel like my 7s are... It's just gonna keep going forever.
Doki, read the seed.
What's the seed?
Where is it?
Oh, it's a tutorial.
Hey guys, I did it.
Alright, you will stop.
Oh, it scales?
Okay, let's start in endless mode.
Do I just click?
There you go.
And that is why it stops you.
I promise you, it won't.
True victory is written in scientific notation.
Sombra, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Aphelion, thank you for the 777.
The true victory.
This is the most balutro run I've seen from the tutorial seed.
First run, take it higher.
Thank you for the super chat, Tsunami.
Thank you, thank you.
Justin, thank you for the Hakasupa.
Do I still get to keep my deck in endless mode?
Guys, bro, I've never won a run and you win on your first.
What is this tree?
Okay, let's go.
I'll fight.
Yeah.
Nice.
How do you beat the game?
You don't.
Don't you.
Permanently gain plus one.
Oh, I like that.
I get one plus one discard each round?
Wait, five of a kind?
Isn't five of a kind...
Five cards with the same... Wait, isn't five of a kind... I could just have sevens?
Wait!
Alright, I'm gonna buy this voucher.
Wait, Planet X first.
Yeah, I'm gonna buy and use.
Yeah.
I'm gonna get Planet X so I can get...
And then I'll buy the voucher so I can get an extra discard.
And then...
I'll get an Arcana pack because I have the money anyway.
Oh my god!
And then I'll use the four so I can get another Planet X.
And then I'll use Planet X again.
And then I'll buy another Celestial pack.
And then...
And then... Oh, I get to level up four of a kind again.
Let's go.
Four of a kind.
Let's...
Alright.
Okay, a hundred and ten.
Let's see, I'll get rid of all these guys fast.
And then...
Oh, I could steal another... Oh my god, let's steal another one.
Fuck it.
Let's just steal another...
No, why would I steal a heart?
I'm gonna use the heart anyway, right?
But why a heart?
Because I'm gonna use... In case you get six.
What the fuck am I gonna do with a six?
Steal a heart for big... Yeah, but I have to not use a heart though.
Oh, so I can keep... Oh!
Okay.
I'll steal it.
I'll steal a heart.
I see... I see what you mean.
And then...
In case I have six, you're right.
In case I have six sevens, you're so right.
Nice.
Yeah.
One, two, three.
Let's get... Let's have more sevens in here.
Alright, that's cool.
No.
No, I'll take it.
Yeah.
Let's go.
That's fine with me.
Oh shit, I accidentally used a steal.
Whoops.
I already won.
It's fine.
I literally got 530.
There we go.
Your entire card, poker hand, plus one hand size.
Oh shit, Jumbo Arcana.
Hermit, Wheel of Fortune, Star, converts up to... Converts up to three cards.
Oh, I don't have more hearts.
God damn it.
I... Oh my god.
Wait, fuck.
Okay.
Oh no, but then I have... I get to make more sevens.
Shit.
But what about sevens?
You're right.
It's all about gambling.
You're so right, guys.
But Wheel is for content.
Alright.
Alright, Pluto.
It's time for more Pluto.
I'm gonna have like one card that would just let me... All face cards.
All face cards are... Wait.
Face cards are kings and queens, right?
Oh, that doesn't matter to me.
That doesn't fucking matter to me.
Oh, I got to play this hand.
And then I clone another one.
Wow.
And then I just get rid of these guys.
And then I get rid of these guys.
And then I win.
66k for FC.
Pluto!
I can't get over this.
Bro, what the fuck?
Bro, like, I don't know how to feel about her.
I told you Pluto's a real planet!
Oh my god!
I can make it!
Okay, wait.
This is two selected cards.
Wait, I can turn my sevens into bonus cards!
Wait, I can multi.
Wait.
Wait, but Empress though!
Yeah, but I... Three.
I can only... I only have one, two.
Okay, you're right.
And then... And then I'll convert.
More hearts.
You're right.
These are all kind of... Oh, more hearts though.
And the five?
Okay, we'll do it.
But then I can have plus enhances too.
But I can have multipliers though.
You need more hearts for... Go for the five later for strength.
Oh, you're true.
But the multi!
You want more hearts?
But you only... You're right.
I only want hearts.
You're fucking right, guys.
You're right.
You're so right, guys.
I need to buy another seven.
I'm running out.
God damn it.
Guys, I'm running out of sevens.
You don't understand.
I need more.
Guys, you don't understand.
I'm running out.
I need more sevens.
Alright, nice.
I win.
Oh no, the plant went out.
I'm quite fond of the palatial flush.
Nice.
I'm riding.
I'm riding it all the way to the bank!
Plus one consumable slot.
Wait, is it this one?
The top right?
What the fuck?
I'll buy that.
Alright.
Now I have three.
And then you know what that means.
Misprint?
Do I get this?
But I don't want to sell it in my cards.
I can't.
These are all too good.
Nah, all of it is too good.
I need more sevens though.
I'm fucking run... God damn it.
Why is it giving me tens?
I don't need tens.
No!
Why does it keep giving me tens?
I don't understand.
Alright.
How much do I make now?
Seventy seven thousand...
Five hundred and sixty.
Let's see.
It's getting... Okay, nevermind.
I won.
It's getting real... Oh, nevermind.
I just won.
Wait, I didn't win instantly?
What is this?
What?
Oh, nevermind.
I won again.
Oh my...
No.
Nevermind.
That's why you need steals.
This is where it starts.
Oh my God, it's ramping up like fucking crazy.
Holy shit.
Wow, guys, that's shit.
It's actually... It's getting harder.
Oh, the ante is actually going up now.
Guys!
I think... Guys!
Oh my God.
Guys, are you telling me seven is not the... No, seven is always the answer.
No, they're all wrong.
Seven is always the answer.
Get in there, Pluto.
Get in there.
Oh, I could've strengthened!
I forgot about the strength!
Oh my God.
I forgot.
Oh no.
I'm so sad.
Oh my God.
Okay.
Okay, I multiply.
I got the multiplier.
It's okay.
I always have the multiplier.
I just...
Here we go.
I can do this.
Get rid of all of you.
And then...
I could get another heart.
There is a chance I'll get another heart.
This isn't looking too good, guys.
Nevermind.
It always is looking good for Doki.
Oh yeah, another seven.
I'll just discard this just in case.
Let's discard this.
There we go.
Seven for the W.
How long will it take me?
How long is it gonna take me to the finish line?
You just can't keep getting away with this.
Yes, I will.
That's one hand size.
Oh my God.
Bro, the antes is getting higher.
I'm a little scared, guys.
I'm getting a little scared, guys.
Add negative to a random joker.
Destroy five random cards in hand.
Oh my God.
No, they're all sevens.
Wait, what do I use for this?
Ecto?
But which one?
Skip?
Oh, it's random?
Why are your cards all seven?
It's risky.
It is very risky.
It's fine!
Go!
I'm all about the risk.
I gotta believe in my- Whoa, what the fuck is this?
Dude, this card is hella- It's always held in hand at the end of- Oh, fuck it.
Let's go.
I mean, it's fucking- Whoa, I'll take that.
Yeah, I might as well.
I already bought it anyway.
Like, I already bought it.
Oh, buy another- Oh, whoops.
After play or discard, always draw three cards.
What does this mean?
This one sucks?
Alright.
Start with zero discards.
Okay, this- That's fine.
I'll just clone a seven.
Guys, it's GG, guys.
It was- Alright, guys.
It was nice knowing you all.
It was- It was nice knowing you all again.
Guys,
we had a good- We had a good run.
We had- Guys, we had- We had- We had a good run, guys.
Okay, if I play bad cards, it'll be fine.
I'll just play all these bad cards.
Yeah.
It'll be fine.
And then, like...
Truly...
Oh, no.
Four of a kind.
Guys, four of a kind!
Four of a kind!
Can we save this?
Save this seal?
But four of a kind!
Get flush five?
But then I have to use these.
I have to use the pair.
Is it worth it?
But will I- Do I win?
Okay.
Maybe.
Oh my God.
Is that enough?
This is my last one.
Oh, that's enough.
It's fine.
I just got saved.
I made it.
Yeah, I made it.
Yippee!
I made it.
The dream is still alive!
How does she keep getting away with this?
Oh my God, that's more money!
Wait, what?
Go up to minus $20 in debt?
Wait, I don't wanna go in debt.
Wait, plus one card shop.
Oh, buy the voucher.
Yeah, I'll buy it.
Oh, they're selling money?
I can't believe your luck is driving me insane.
Wait,
I should get...
Wait, is this free money?
Does this give me money?
I can't tell what this is.
No?
Oh, no.
Okay, I'll get free money first.
And I'll use it.
Oh, and then I'll buy this.
I'll buy this, and then I'll get all jokers, and then I'll have more money.
No?
Oh, don't buy it?
Okay.
Oh, it's a bad joker.
Okay, I'll just get money then.
And I'll reroll.
Doubles all listed probabilities.
1 in 3 to 2 to 3.
Do I have probabilities?
Adds the number of times Poker Hand has been played this run.
Earn an extra $1 of interest for every $5 you have.
Wait, they're all good.
Wait, space?
Is it this one?
To the moon?
To the moon!
Alright.
Okay.
I'll get a... Oh, I'll get more Celestial Pack.
Go to the far left?
Okay.
I'll buy another Celestial Pack.
Oh, nice.
More Aeris.
Yippee!
What's my card looking like now?
Oh, that's pretty nice.
That's a pretty nice looking deck.
Alright, let's go!
Alright.
Let's see.
I don't think I need any of this.
I don't know if I need probability.
Look at the... Oh, you're right.
I gotta look at the boss.
Alright, go next.
Oh my God!
Guys, I think it's over.
I think it's over.
I... I don't...
Seven, you've been with me for so long.
Seven, it's...
Oh, seven to seven to the seven run.
Oh, seven to the seven run.
I don't know if I should risk trying to get another heart.
I don't know.
I don't know if I should get a flush or...
Oh, seven.
You did your job.
Oh, you did your job, seven.
You were good to me.
Nah, we're... I can't.
There's no way.
Defeated by a seven.
Wait, what's better?
Four or... Okay.
Four of a kind, 190, flush five.
Oh my God.
If it was flush five, we would have...
Okay, four of a kind.
Then you play with one other unscroll... Okay, we gotta... We can only play this.
Four of a kind.
With the same rank.
Wait, is this...
Five of a kind.
Oh, the multiplier.
Alright.
Oh, seven.
Wait, space adds into... Oh my God, you're right!
I forgot about the space!
Wait.
Wait, do I put five?
Five for... Okay.
Maybe this is it.
Maybe the supernova's gonna hit it.
Maybe.
Oh my God, look at all the multipl... Oh my God, it's keep going.
Oh my God, it... Oh no, it's over.
Goodbye.
It's over.
Guys.
It's not enough.
It's actually not.
It's so over.
Unless...
Unless everybody...
No, it's so over.
I don't think I can get...
It's never... It's never been...
Guys, I don't even think a flush five would save us.
You must keep trying.
Wait.
It's over, guys.
I'll discard the two.
I'll discard the three.
Wait.
If I do... Wait, I can do two pairs.
And then maybe I'll get another heart.
And then maybe...
Oh my God.
We can get... We might be able to get...
We might be... We might be able to get a flush five.
Right here.
Right now.
Oh my God.
Guys, I think it's over.
I don't think it's gonna...
I don't think we're gonna get seven million.
I don't... Okay, yeah.
Guys, we've had a good run.
We've had a good run.
The seven, seven, seven run.
Oh, seven to the sevens.
It was a good run, guys.
Oh, seven...
Seven died to the seven million.
Only the seven million could kill the seven run.
It...
All good things must come to an end.
Oh, that was fun.
Oh, I can't... I can't believe...
I can't believe I first tried it as a creator.
I heard, like, people were struggling so much.
We were struggling in the tutorial.
Like, for the first, like, first trying tutorial.
I can't believe I made it.
I can't believe I got it through.
Oh, I had very good luck.
Oh my God, Kaz, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You were a good seven.
Real good.
Maybe even the best 07, everybody.
07, the luckiest run of my life.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Grunga, thank you for the super chat.
Wait, ununlocked stuff?
What did I unlock?
Plus one hen.
Oh, I unlocked... Oh, that's where the rogue light is.
Oh, wait, I get better cards?
Wait, what the fuck?
Wait, that's crazy.
Wait, I got through all of that without even getting any of the...
Pyro, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Without playing a straight... Wait, that's me.
I just played one number and that's it.
Unlocked like half the...
I won a run, let's go.
Start one with a crystal ball voucher.
Nice.
Max up the interest per round earnings for 10 consecutive rounds.
Have at least 30 cards of heart suited in your deck.
That's me.
One or two chance for play cards to give you...
Oh my god, I could have had it all.
Enhance 16 cards in your multi.
You have at least 16...
What the fuck?
I could have had all of this.
I could... What do you mean?
I just had a baby deck.
Each played ace of spades gives...
Oh my god, all I had was an actual baby deck.
That's crazy.
What the fuck was my luck?
Phillip, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Happy new year, Doki.
You've been popping up like crazy ever since your comeback stream last year.
And the amazing heights you've been reaching just keep on coming.
Here's to many more awesome memories in 2025.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you, Phillip.
My mom, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This is the power of the top 500 Marble Rival player.
Guys, what's the cutoff?
I have an hour left.
Did I make it?
Did I...
Am I fine?
Did I make it?
Oh, I'm fine.
Okay, that's cool.
Alright, I'm alright now.
I'm alright.
Why did you bring up Marble Rivals?
Because I need to know if I made it.
I need to know.
There's an hour left of the season.
Alright.
Greg, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Great first round.
0-7 to the sevens.
Wait, there's still three hours left.
Oh my god.
Oh, I'm ranked.
Okay.
Cutoff is 5-0-3-6.
Oh, wait.
No, I'm not 5-0.
Oh, I'm still 2.
Okay, that's fine.
Alright, we're okay.
I'm okay.
Okay, sorry guys.
I just freaked out a little bit because the season ends in like an hour.
So I died.
I just have to be sure, okay?
I just have to be sure if I have to put up Marble Rivals.
Alright, anyway guys.
That was a crazy run.
I didn't expect to beat the game in one try.
Like the tutorial.
I guess like the first run in one try.
I legitimately did not know what I was doing.
But then the seven gods graced us with the power of seven.
And we made it so far.
We made it so fucking far with just seven.
So 0-7 everybody.
That was fun though.
That was actually a really fun game.
I definitely enjoyed it.
I think like it's definitely more fun because I'm playing it with you guys too.
Like I'm learning the game like as I go along.
So I thought it was incredibly seven.
What a fucking run though.
I feel like if it was anyone that had to experience all of that.
It's funny that it was me.
Like I feel like it's very like of course it was me that had to experience this for my very first bilateral run.
Anyway, I'm gonna call it here.
Everyone, I feel like I should end it at a high note.
I don't know.
I feel like the seven run was pure cinema.
And I feel like I should end that in a high note with the most pure cinema run I've ever had.
Which was my first run.
MrBrokenBot, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No, no one game of Marble Rivals.
If I'm safe, then we'll do a Marble...
We have a Marble Rivals stream at 1 in the morning, guys.
No Marble Rivals right now.
We have another stream today at 1 AM, guys.
We don't need to do another one right now.
I'm gonna take a nap.
But I had so much fun.
I hope you guys had a lot of fun watching.
As always, everybody stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you did that for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.